welcome back to New Rockstars it's time
for our annual tradition of looking back
on our year of theories wolf down a
slice of humble pie or I guess in this
case a heavy pour of guilt from our man
bar man bechtold as we all review what
we got wrong and uh yeah we're starting
a little early for our new rock stars
holiday party hopefully you know we'll
get this rolling soon but um Tommy I
wanted to confess to you some theories
that I got wrong in 2022 and uh come
clean on some things oh your secrets are
safe with me Eric are you sure about
that no one's recording this are they no
this is just you and I on a hot set with
Mike's cameras and lights
I can't see any of that I tuned it all
out all right I live a cursed existence
as does our man Deadpool because that's
the first thing I really got wrong this
year I said Deadpool would appear in
doctor strange and the Multiverse of
Madness to the left of that dot some
claim you can see the image of Deadpool
shushiness perhaps in a post-graded
scene or when strange in America Chavez
tumble through realities With The
Dinosaurs you could easily imagine
Deadpool get knocked loose and sucked
into that chaos crash landed with them
wherever they land what was I thinking
it's not like a movie poster led me
wrong oh wait it totally did there was a
Shard it looked like Deadpool Twitter
said it was Deadpool I believed it was
Deadpool it makes sense Deadpool would
have showed up everyone else did yeah
and Twitter is very reliable I can
understand why you got confused by that
what else well I also said that Deadpool
and She-Hulk are both talking to the
Watcher both of these characters as part
of their powers have an ability to break
reality who was that audience maybe the
Watcher whom Thor living Thunder
confirmed exists in some live-action
form they might be I guess that's not
confirmed or denied yet well that's
tough to say Eric I'd love to hear a
little bit more about what you got wrong
it sounds like you're enjoying this no
no no but there's a reason why they're
only showing me from the waist up
all right
uh well speaking of She-Hulk I did say
that Jake the goat is a Mephisto
reference oh my God oh my God that is
him
that's topisto I feel like it was
available Vista reference right but I
did say based off of that that mephista
would show up in werewolf by night that
named Jake could be setting up Mephisto
to appear in werewolf by night with Jack
Russell I know I've had girlfriends so I
can't get over either Eric it's tough to
let go of things I have let go of him he
won't let go of me ah yes there's that
Twitter again yeah he he appears in my
dreams yes uh but of course but this so
did not show up in werewolf by night I
said that the court of owls would appear
in the Batman I went pretty hard on that
one I suggest that this Batman without
realizing it might be carrying out the
will of the court of owls a Talon type
Patsy executioner who claims to be
justice but for a court of Lies I
actually was with you on that so I'm not
gonna say anything there were so many so
much owl imagery in that yeah but uh
there was enough going on in that movie
and we don't need the court of owls yet
I really messed up something towards the
end of the year I said that Mark Hamill
cameo in the Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special mark Campbell himself
doesn't uncredit a cameo as a part of
your chugging some liquor the Santa
inflatable deflates and drops onto his
dumb hat but it wasn't it's just a guy
who looks like him the actor's name was
Troy Beacham Troy I'm sorry never meant
to hurt you never meant to make you cry
but tonight we're cleaning out our
closets that's right
uh yeah you're really beating yourself
up here Eric and I I I just got to say I
could hear a little more okay all right
well uh Buckle in because I said that
shuri would resurrect killmonger from
The ancestral plane and shuri is in the
ancestral plane recruiting cousin
killmonger to wake him up to resurrect
him that could be how we get killmonger
back in the suit now shuri did meet
killmonger in the ancestral plane but
Michael B Jordan's character was not
resurrected to help fight and claim any
black panther title more I said that
shuri uh I actually went pretty hard on
this I said sure he would not be the
Black Panther in this movie I said it
was going to be Nakia Okoye and and
umbaku as part of like a trio I think
the mantle of black panther will succeed
from one hero to Chala to a team of
three Heroes not Kia and green Okoye and
door milage red and mbaku in Black the
Alvin Simon Theodore if you will is
there a Dave in this scenario is that
ever K Ross I think yeah I think he is
he's the Dave in every scenario uh you
know I think we got just some fan
fiction to write more than than anything
I wouldn't feel bad about that more
wrong things you got okay Thor 11
Thunder I said that the planet that they
were on uh and when in the opening
sequence was Centauri for yondu's home
world just based on the fact that the
people were blue I I just concluded that
they were centurions now this
blue-skinned race is actually the same
tribe that the Guardians fight alongside
in the other shots I'm thinking they're
the zatoan tribe of the planet Century 4
the saint tribe as yandu and that uh
we're looking at the aftermath in that
same solar system of century six the
planet that was destroyed by the
hatching of a Celestial representing
eternals and it could be on this Planet
Centauri 4 where Thor and the Guardians
learn the story of a nearby planet named
Centauri six in their system with one
very pissed off Soul Survivor because he
comes from that Century sixth planet
that was destroyed in order to birth the
celestial it was not part of the century
system it was just a planet called
indigar yeah that was really bad yeah
that was you feeling okay I'm I am
actually feeling better it's it's good
oh good good well that's what we're here
for more uh I said that Beta Ray Bill
was removed from a shot in a Thor 11
Thunder trailer the way they framed this
shot weird empty space on the left
beside the work
the shot was framed for three three
characters and
they made a ray bill or someone else
might have been digitally removed from
this trailer he wasn't I also said that
Jane Foster's cancer came from her
exposure to The Ether it was never
really explained I also speculated that
Jane might have some connection to the
cosmic entity of infinity and when one
of those stones was used to cosmically
Doom one woman that is exactly the kind
of Greek tragedy plight that a God Like
Infinity might take mercy upon and that
had nothing to do with it you know what
I think she talked her cell phone into
her bra next
bartenders are irreverent I said that
the guards and werewolf by night were
TBA Hunters Jack is prodded by these
armed soldiers that I'm pretty sure are
TVA hunters from Loki they weren't but I
gotta admit it looked they look they had
some cattle prods that looked very
menacing and prune-like yeah I think
that was a fair assessment to make but
uh it wasn't at all connected to the TVA
I wouldn't beat yourself up over that
but why don't you give us something to
beat yourself up over okay this one was
pretty effed up I thought that Cameron's
mother najma at first that you know and
Miss Marvel at the end of episode two I
thought she was related to Kamala making
Kamala related to kamran I thought they
were cousins because if najma aka the
woman from the Visions is kamala's great
grandmother Aisha if she's not also
Cameron's mother Cameron might be
kamala's grand uncle that was my gut
reaction that first episode yeah and I'm
like or to that second episode I'm like
I hope they're not related is that
really where they're going because I
just thought that yeah we get that on
HBO we're not at Disney Plus for that
type of content yeah that was stupid and
then I thought the idea that Kamala
would I really thought that uh she
wasn't going to be revealed as a mutant
that was one of the things speculated I
really thought she would either be
called an inhuman or if they didn't use
the word inhuman would just come up with
some other term for her I was shocked as
Eddie yeah happily surprised I don't
have a problem with her being a mutant
yeah uh that's a lot man I'm gonna be
honest I'm in a bad mood now and I came
in here fresher off of a hangout with my
lady if you know what I mean but you
know what I got some stuff right too oh
sure let's hear some of that damn it I
said that Charles Xavier Patrick Stewart
was gonna be in Multiverse Madness I
said that all the way back in December
20. you were actually really busy right
now man I don't know hold on I said that
a Sweet Child of Mine in a Thor 11
Thunder trailer I said that it had to do
I was the only one who said it but I did
say it and then you know I based on read
Richard's lines and Multiverse
management so there's all headed to
Secret Wars and then a Comic-Con they
revealed that they proved me right and
you know what Mephisto may not be in the
MCU yet but but freaking uh Zeus said
that uh he confirmed the existence of
Satan in the MCU in the background it
was then captioned when it came out on
Disney plus but Mephisto lives he's in
the MCU hey
sweet boy
let's get you a glass of water and let's
get you out of here okay okay all right
have a great New Year I'm right
mephisto's still alive who's next you
look like you've had a few I've had more
from the field Tommy I've
I've been feeling quite regretful about
hey about a series that I've gotten
wrong this year this is a place of no
judgment you talk to your bartender I'm
here to help what do you want to get off
your chest I haven't had a theory a long
time ago that Todd from She-Hulk was
going to be a villain called madman and
it was wrong in the comics that weirdo
Samuel has a brother named Philip
Stearns who also decides to invest in
the family business by becoming the
gamma-powered Hulk villain known as
madman and that's why I believe this
Hawk Todd is supposed to be Africa Todd
was no one he was just a Todd man I mean
I feel like a lot of people made
inferences about Todd that went around
and beat yourself up over that and I
also have a feeling that the leader was
going to cam you at the end of that
series but guess what it was Kevin and
robot Kevin it was yeah it was a robot
with a hat I mean that whole series was
so cheeky though you can't [ __ ] you're
very interesting you can't blame
yourself very very cheap did you see see
the cheeks it was very cheeky oh
yeah but there was another one that I
thought that you know there was a
villain in Marvel Comics named despair
yeah I thought despair was gonna be
despair the villain behind Multiverse
give me you got 15 seconds to give me a
primer on despair he's white that sounds
like my family but he's essentially just
a demon okay and um I thought that
despair was going to play a role but uh
despair the person never showed up I see
that was despair
these are the spirits yes the spirits
yes I have too many imagine my body I'm
actually doing some stand-up now I'm
taking a class okay I'm gonna get out of
this bar thank you but this was from
last year but I think about it daily huh
I thought that Mysterio was going to be
Andrew and Toby And I just apparently
that was just real Spiderman I thought
there were gonna be Illusions Okay and
like there's gonna be I got you
everybody know told me no Andrew or
maybe potentially and this is what I
think personally that these two could
very much be Mysterio Illusions because
Andrew Garfield is very much saying I'm
not coming back as Spider-Man okay
apparently they were just like we want
to do family service I do something
great and okay you know he's a little
drunk right now guys he doesn't mean
that I'm not drunk there's also I
thought that Arthur Harrell is going to
be a villain called the Sun King oh and
I think that What's Happening Here is
that Arthur hero is slowly becoming the
Sun King and they're they're mixing up
the characters he's just a broken
glasses by sandals man apparently I
don't know there's just some guy okay is
that it well yeah my
or did you think you were gonna get away
with not admitting your gravity and time
travel Theory oh yes my yes my gravity
travel Theory I know I'm just a
bartender but uh well you know you
you'll get familiar with my failures all
right
some would say I'm obsessed with them
why are we on the subject of mood night
I thought that this the the entirety of
the planet would back in time two
thousand years because the stars of the
sky shifted guys if this is the case and
the Earth has been sent two thousand
years into the versus past you guys know
what this means and to this day I still
live because I believe that the time
travel [ __ ] is going to happen with Kang
in the future and they're setting
something up all right I never accuse
people of this did you sneak your own
booze into this box listen
ing happened outside someone gave me
something oh thank you hey hey
Charlie keep an eye on him okay Charlie
get away from me
Charles Barkley oh are bouncing in this
fiction all right what'd you get right
before I kick you out of this place I I
got right that Herbert Luciano I mean um
High evolutionary Herbert was going to
be the villain of volume three I thought
that was fun
um I thought I got right but Deadpool
was gonna be involved with the TVA
that's going to be really I think that's
good enough do we really need to
celebrate everyone's victories here
we're trying to make people feel better
I noticed you guys wrote paragraphs for
yourselves about what you got right I I
knew that LeapFrog was driving that
green sports car yeah because it's green
like frogs ribbit ribbon and then I do
that day boards Dragon Powers is gonna
connect see their
quetzalcoat or cool cool you're on
Quaaludes right now wow don't tell
nobody I knew that the leader was going
to be in caps for my greatest victory Of
The Year all right get out of here okay
who's next don't scream mushrooms
okay oh just give me just give me a Wawa
Wawa on the Rocks okay I don't first of
all I don't have time to be here I need
to be writing a script right now but my
sister's because you don't want to admit
what you got wrong you didn't shake that
that's also sparkly I need still it's
also open so you pick your place in here
that's fair okay no listen can we talk
Mario just real quick because no one
else wants to talk it with me and I
really need to talk about Mario I'm a
bartender I love talking Mario great
talking whatever you want as long as you
got cash listen I just
have something okay
okay but it's kind of not my fault
because I got really blurry footage it
was 720p footage and so everything was a
little blurry in the background I might
have thought that a frying pan was
sticking out of a building it wasn't a
frying pan it turned out I also thought
there was this little satellite on a
building that was right in front of it
and turned out wasn't a bright fan it
wasn't a satellite it was actually just
a signpost that was holding up a hamper
and what I thought was a frying pan and
satellite in the blurry footage last
time turned out to be a hanging Hammer
sign which is more than likely
signifying a tool Anna Anna let me stop
you right here do you currently believe
you're being followed by anyone
there are toads everywhere I turn Tommy
we're gonna get you the help you need
did you hear anything right I I got
I got you okay
everybody seems very confident in what
they got right they're very upset about
what they got wrong go ahead lay it on
us well the trick is Tommy if you don't
make any predictions on air because
you're barely ever on the channel then
you get on right you don't get very
strong damn double homicide there you go
oh yes I predicted God would be behind
The Wrecking Crew nice I I did that they
would not talk about Jennifer's blood in
that episode
[Music]
last one you wouldn't see another as
guardian you wouldn't see
time well you bet your ass guardian we
did not great job can you
yeah sure just give it
a little smooch on the side yeah oh yeah
all right cup is stoically still all
right let's get her out of here next
I had this one wrapped up for you ready
to rock
that's ice cold babe
but you know I just got this French
Manny so I ain't popping top yeah no
that's fair my nails are um
what's up babe lay it on me am I a bad
person no not at all is this why my dad
left no your dad left because oh yeah
it's another story I got some fairies I
was gonna say that's actually a theory
video I have coming out on the channel
did he know
it's just a really hard time of year for
me oh babe no it's okay you could cry
this is a safe space to cry I might cry
when everyone leaves
I'll definitely cry when everyone leaves
I have a problem with villains oh boy
and I keep
so much more power ful than they
actually are it's like Jesus Christ
Tommy I really thought I really thought
that the Mind flayer was more powerful
than even vechna Dustin calls vecna the
Mind players five star general but why
is that the case why would the psionic
force team up with vecna instead of
Simply incorporating him into a sive
mind quote Dustin was his five-star
general
that he wasn't he was controlling the
Mind Slayer the whole time he [ __ ]
basically invented the Mind player yeah
and I got that wrong why do we keep
giving these men this power over us when
are we gonna make it about us the strong
beautiful women that we are I agree I
agree way worse than Neymar yeah all
reports indicate that Neymar will be the
primary villain of the movie but comic
fans know that this anti-hero has played
on the side of the Avengers from time to
time so we might see the makings of a
Redemption story in his character art
similar to how the first black panther
focused on an internal fight for the
wakandan throne nemour's position of
leadership might not be uncontested and
a tumor could be seeking to oust also I
thought it was going to be Namor and
then it was no more what the [ __ ] was
that uh well it means the unlovable
that's why my mom calls me no more
what am I gonna do babe come on you're
young you're beautiful there's gonna be
so many shitty bad guys out there to
trick you into thinking they're powerful
I know they told us Michael Myers is
gone for good but do you really believe
that just like your dad Michael Myers is
going to show up when you least expect
it and he's gonna get violent oh my God
you're absolutely right you're
absolutely
absolutely hey I only get to make sense
because I have great friends like you
did you get anything right this year
no idea bro
I want to let you guys know that I'm
stoned most of my personal time and I
have no [ __ ] idea what I wrote this
year uh and it's like we always say if
you get something right you celebrate
all night you celebrate all night that's
right you get something wrong you you
tuck it in your song and you move on
um
I'm sure I got stuff
I know remember I'll tell you what you
got right what being a wonderful
roommate you know what I got right
when you be my roommate this year in the
office who's next
meow just when I thought it was safe to
get back on Grindr hello sorry I brought
a roadie I hope you don't mind no
problem I'm pouring myself a little
sippy sap Tommy Tommy Tommy it's been a
rough year man a rough year yeah
I've had to give a ton of theories on
the break room Orion big questions we've
been really putting you through one of
those Theory pasta makers we just make
you a flatter and flatter and more
lifeless until what's left
I had this crazy prediction that
She-Hulk was gonna walk away are you
okay
I had this crazy prediction time that
She-Hulk was gonna walk away from the
legal profession after being so
disgusted by blonsky's treatment and she
was gonna meet up with Val and join the
Thunderbolts it's gonna be so mad at
Bruce for being like you're the
strongest man in the world why have you
not stopped this why have you not right
broken the chains of your oppressors and
she's gonna be like I'm gonna stand in
it and then Val's gonna hit her at the
right moment and be like do you want to
make some change do you really want to
change yeah
[Music]
not yet although you and I both agreed
as we held hands at the d23 panel
there's a lot of room on that poster
that's right I'm here to make you feel
better what else you get wrong Tommy I
thought for the final episode of moon
night they were gonna have a tie-in to
Black Panther wakanda forever yeah
they're in Egypt Black Panthers and
wakanda it's all Africa just walk down
the street and say hello Moon Knight
it's gonna be black panther they're
gonna tie in Black Panther we're in
Egypt we're in Africa right there's
Egyptian gods and this will get I'll get
into this one a little bit more but you
got that wrong I got it wrong we don't
even know when Moon Knight was yes well
did you have any other Moon Knight
theories
I did I did I thought on moon night it
would be revealed that Jake was the
Prime personality that he was the big
man uh I think the twist is gonna be
we're gonna find out that Jake
was once always and forever the original
he's the alpha personality Jake the
alpha person and Mark and Stephen are
both
fresh personalities he's not he's just
another personality and the personality
suit but he's Spanish He Speaks espanol
ah CC Senor I also said the Thunderbolts
this is crazy Tommy what was I thinking
I said the Thunderbolts movie would be
renamed the Young Avengers versus the
Thunder both at d23 it wasn't we'll
speak preview uh I still think they're
gonna change the name of thunderbolts to
like Thunderbolt Thunderbolts versus
Young Avengers
anyway event hey you will keep it down
back there hey hey hey hey also make a
Young Avengers movie already because
these Young Avengers are already getting
old I hate when these capoeira classes
come in and just drink all night all
right listen are they dancing are they
fighting I don't know who knows all I
know is it's Brazilian and it's gorgeous
yeah it is it is what else you get wrong
oh boy I said that there would be a big
death of someone close to Kamala Khan on
the first episode of Miss Marvel they up
to the rating I thought they were gonna
go hardcore I think there's gonna be a
Spider-Man asks Uncle Ben scenario in
this first episode where someone close
to her dies oh I think it's gonna be a
little heavy wow a little heavier than
we thought all they did was mention
cocaine oh much wrong yeah much much
wrong so incorrect much wrong sad Doge
uh I also thought remember Kenobi
no yes yeah do you want to remember
Kenobi I do another I held Eric Sandra
this was my best theory Tommy okay at
the end and the final episode of Kenobi
it would be revealed that hajja the man
protect Kingo we all know Bingo
pretending to be a Jedi it would be
revealed that he does have the force he
would impress a female Jedi they would
fall in love they'd have a love child
but be unable to afford it give it up
for adoption it would end up on that
gambling planet in the Last Jedi as that
little kid cleaning the stable I think
uh Hajj is gonna wind up uh have using
the force impressing like a female Jedi
he runs across they get married they
make love they have a child and then
they sell the child to that casino and
that's the child with the broom child
trafficking in the Star Wars Universe
needs to be addressed I go on some blogs
Lucas Anon where I talk about all the
conspiracies no I think you're right
that was really uh that was really
excitable you got a lot wrong this year
I did and you got promoted I did get
promoted and I got after all this wrong
well I got some things kind of right I'm
gonna claim them right oh yeah okay look
at Dano you got a few more of these to
get through
I predicted for She-Hulk I predicted the
first episode that that weird pictures
of the 80s Jennifer Walters and Bruce
Banner that would be uh the opening for
the premiere it was actually the opening
for the finale so I'm gonna take credit
for that I'm gonna give you the thinnest
oh give me orange slice thank you thank
you thank you so much I also thought um
I also thought that nightmare would be
the villain in Multiverse events because
remember how many times they said
nightmare in the trailer yeah nightmare
he said that's nightmare standing across
from me in the scene yeah he wasn't in
the movie that's fine but in Scott's
Derek Scott derrickson's version he was
going to be in the moods right we saw
the concept he's not a horse they had
Concepts
animatics Tommy and I also I predicted
that Captain Marvel would appear in the
final episode of Miss Marvel but that's
the easiest prediction in the world to
make I rarely say this what you got
wrong far outweighed what you got right
everything you said in your wrong
section was Despicable everything you
got right could have been predicted by a
child get out of here you're right I
gotta get home oh no get the stretcher
get the stretcher Dolly that's what I
want get the dolly get the get the man
wheeler out here or woman wheeler let's
make her story who's next
I need five drinks
what can I get you my lady and these
drinks like a chimney around the house
whatever you what have you fancy okay
you have ice or cups or any other crops
so what you're getting is a whole orange
oh okay I'll peel it during this it
seems so practical Tommy yeah you know I
can fight in you all the time yeah babe
tell me your secrets I honestly bet
against the Buffalo Bills that was the
first mistake I made last call
thank you
I said
She-Hulk and Daredevil will only be
friends and I guess it's because I hate
sex this has potential to be the
Friendship origin story and that's
really all I want because Daredevil
needs a friend like She-Hulk and she
helped me as a friend like Daredevil
that's just a little bit a little bit of
tea theorization for you I don't know if
that's a word I've theorized there you
go they do
say one more time
[Music]
[Applause]
oh I'm uh I'm playing the piano with my
toes I have one of those keyboards from
Big
um
keep it going while I keep going all
right go ahead tell me more secrets I
said Nikki would die no your best friend
for she held I also said she was a witch
that was I'm sorry everybody thought she
was a witch that's not bad that's not on
you
foreign
the skin I said Todd was related to
hallway which was a stupid idea I said
Abomination was doing all of this just
to fight Bruce again oh yeah I thought
you were right about that though well
yeah because it made sense listen to me
I was I should have been right I
straight up said scar would not show up
and I was very against it because I said
storyline purposes why would you make
him show up in the last three minutes of
an episode yeah and what did he do he
showed up in the last three minutes
exactly so I'm still kind of throwing
that you bet against the bills
you did it to hurt me and you know what
that makes me think you do things to
love me too that is true but you know
what you say to me all the time bro you
got that body that makes me go way like
a baby foreign
that's right they don't they have Geno
Smith he pretends to be a quarterback
like I pretend to be an actor either way
oh you are an actor either way we're
both serving deep dish pizzas in five
years so let's go oh my God even after
seeing the photo I still believed it was
Johnny Blaze instead of Donnie Blaze oh
yeah because I'm an idiot that's okay do
you get anything right sweetie um I got
actually one thing right what'd you get
the the Buffalo Bills suck
um
foreign
are you taking those shots no I'm joking
Buffalo Bills are great I love them I
only buy those kinds of gifts for Tommy
um I said Layla would be the best
you were right about that that's the
only thing I was wrong but you slandered
the bills so get out of here okay I'm on
my way anyone else need a drink before I
I get out of here hi Tommy Zach great to
see you you and I have tipped a few back
in the day oh we've had a few drinks in
our lives what one to ten or maybe 30.
I'm I'm here purely for social reasons
because as we all know I didn't get
anything wrong this year that's right
that's actually not true there's a few
uh key things I did uh get wrong uh of
course I mostly just appear on the break
room yeah you're off in there that's
what I um where we don't necessarily
propose a lot of theories we sometimes
have predictions I got a lot of
predictions wrong I said for sure uh
Queen Ramona would not die in Black
Panther what kind of forever I said
there would be multiple black panthers
in wakanda Forever uh almost everything
I I you know what queen Ramona got for
Christmas no neither is she because
she's dead
Jesus not funny but there are two things
from the break room uh that I definitely
got wrong yeah for example one of the
earliest episodes we did I said that the
french actor yeah Gaspard ulio who was
in Moon Knight who tragically passed
away uh in an accident before his
episode aired I said he was a terrible
actor in that scene yes
um and I said the scenes that he was in
were really bad
um but anyways I did get some stuff
wrong this year
whatever I mean again I as I did then no
thoughts and prayers to his family his
loved ones of course I wouldn't wish and
his acting coach I would never speak ill
of the dead but I think it's fair to
speak ill of the performances of this
sure they hate us because they faint us
then I uh as a person who sometimes
reads the headlines on the break room
yeah I'm kind of bad at pronunciation
showtimes especially people's names I'm
pretty bad you got Zach Braff wrong one
you called him zulchin sashaya I don't
even know what are you John Travolta I
frequently get uh the Wonder Woman
actress's name
incorrect Christian wig
uh of course you have to pronounce the T
yes it is Gal Gadot yes and when I say
that people are like it's not that it's
good it is but I I stand
now Google says Godot uh uh Google says
take note yeah that's right her name is
Google says know your place behind the
camera John whatever floats your boat
but I I will of the things I got right I
will stand by some people try to correct
me on the barbie and Harley Quinn
actresses pronunciation yes it is Margot
Robbie yeah Margot Robbie Robbie some
people want to say Roby things like that
people yes no he's right because I make
a hobby a studying Margot Robbie you
feel me that's right dogs gonna bark
this Christmas
yes all right well that's it that's it
all right I think that's what everybody
at the company got wrong last call no
need to go anymore how about you Tommy
I don't
think we need to do that I might have
got one or one or two things wrong I
might have got a couple things wrong
very few look you can see my Christmas
pants on ah it's a little Easter egg
there's I call them keister eggs
thank you well
I only got a few things wrong and I
guess in any specific order I said Todd
would build an Iron Man suit and die I
said Todd will have mutant Powers all
predictions about and or wrong including
who would die in specific episodes what
marva's involvement was would we see
Jedis would we see Wookies I had some
wrong information about droids I
actually ran the Andor fantasy league
and still got the points wrong even
though I was in charge of giving out the
points I said Victor Von Doom would be
in wakanda forever and all of a sudden
the guard goes hey you got a visitor and
then the shadowy figure comes through
the door and goes hi I am a diplomat
from blood very oh
you can call me Victor but my friends
call me
doctor do Oh I thought for some reason
they were going to do the Urkel in
wakanda forever and that was my bad that
was never on tap and I said an eternal
would show up in Moonlight oh what MCU
property will tie in hmm what could it
be I think it'll be the eternals however
there was an early drafts a plan for
Kingo to show up in Moon night so I was
almost right the only thing I got right
this year is the only thing this company
is banking on for next year to make any
money and that is Everett Ross is Victor
Von Doom
um
to Tommy back told the richest man in
town
because my dad's rich
I mean on my birth certificate
well Tommy did he get anything right
this year yeah Ross is doing oh yeah oh
what did I get right I think there was
one point in the She-Hulk predictions
where the Trashy chat had way more
points than me but I did predict that
there that uh Derek I said Deadpool
Daredevil and She-Hulk we're gonna get
it on because if there's one thing I
know it's love making
okay well Tommy we love you oh
for all of us here at new rock stars we
want to thank all of you for sticking
with us this year when our theories were
right and when they were wrong or when
they were wrong but they'll be right
someday because the MCU will never stop
making content and neither will we I
want to thank all of our hosts here at
new rock stars we uh we're so grateful
to be able to do this job uh and uh and
to be all here together during the
holidays and uh we got a lot of great
things planned for 2023 you just stay
tuned so be sure to follow all of us on
social media and be nice during this uh
holiday season and uh follow new rock
stars that new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for only the most correct
theories that you can find on YouTube
everyone happy holidays have a nice news
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]